so we have a new cbs news poll asking
american voters about a number of
different things which we will look at
but
one top line that just cannot be missed
is that at this point in time
almost six months out from the november
2020 election
75 percent of trump voters
still believe donald trump's lie that he
won the election
not joe biden 75 percent of trump voters
responded
that no i do not consider joe biden the
legitimate winner
of the 2020 election it's almost as bad
with republicans the idea that there's a
big difference between republicans and
trump voters
70 percent of republicans overall do not
believe
that joe biden is the rightful winner
of the 2020 election if the numbers are
anywhere close to this uh
in reality it is another humiliating
embarrassment for the country
and for critical thinking in the united
states now what do i mean by if the
numbers are close to this in reality
it's an it's a reasonable question to
ask
whether they actually believe it or they
are showing support for their tribe
by claiming to believe it even if they
don't to
send a message to the pollsters to the
media to democrats
to whomever it's a very stupid message
to send if that's what they're doing but
the problem
is that even if they don't actually
believe it but they just say they do on
polls
polling data like this can be used to
justify
or to feign support for all sorts of
things either by protesters or by
republican officials
so it's a problem either way it's
certainly conceivable that there are
some people
who say they don't believe joe biden won
but they kind of do and they're just
saying it for the purposes of messing
with pollsters
another issue we've covered how more
voters
than in a long time have abandoned the
republican party the percentage of
people identifying as republican has
gone down
as a result does it make it more likely
that the trumpists that stay are the
ones most likely to believe any lie that
donald trump tells and that this is less
a shift in the republican party
believing this it's just the people that
still identify
are more of the trumpy wing which is
that why there's only five points of
difference between
republicans and trump supporters in this
particular case
that may be on the other hand thanks to
trump there's lots of previous
non-voters
who joined the republican party so maybe
we can't make such an assessment
other interesting data points from the
poll despite the controversy
in washington dc about infrastructure
spending it's very popular
87 percent of the country wants to spend
money on
improving roads and bridges overall 58
percent of the country approves of joe
biden's
infrastructure big picture that plan
includes money for roads and bridges but
also
building out green infrastructure
hardening and improving the electrical
grid modernizing
building electric car chargers speeding
up transitions to renewable energy many
other
great things that's popular even though
it's not clear a single republican will
vote for it
in the house or senate it's popular
overall joe biden
has a very high approval on vaccine
distribution 72
of the country approves of the job biden
has done on vaccines
even nearly half of republicans say
biden has done well on vaccines
on vaccine hesitancy the numbers they
improved marginally since last month in
this same poll
not by much the number of people who are
saying no to the vaccine
is steady at 22 similar to last month
similar to other polls
the number who or maybes went down from
22 to 18
and the number of yes went up from 55 to
60.
not a massive change just outside the
margin of error
those numbers once we can vaccinate kids
would get us very close if not to herd
immunity
but it would obviously be far better if
we could get the vaccine hesitancy down
to 12 or 15 percent we have a much
better chance
uh if vaccine hesitancy goes down to
that degree
so that's the situation much of it is
disturbing i mean it's very disturbing
of course that 75 percent of trump
voters
now almost six months out from the
election still are saying that donald
trump won most of those people want
trump back and would vote for him again
as recent polling has shown us you also
don't get to numbers like these without
big boosts from media and so we have to
go back to fox news
and to newsmax and to oan and others for
boosting these conspiracies from day one
after the election
continuing to boost them until they
received lawsuit threats and even today
they're still hosting guests who say
this exact same stuff the network
anchors will sort of
stay silent and play more coy with it
but that's a big factor in how people
even came to believe this stuff
it's not clear how we fix it lots of the
people who still think trump won
are the same people who won't wear a
mask indoors and they're the same people
who won't get a vaccine
because they believe it's some kind of
democratic plot
to destroy liberty even though they also
believe trump invented the vaccine
or they think the vaccine will be used
to control their minds or poison them
that's a pretty deep uh you could call
it a delusion or a misunderstanding
effect
that's deep and significant and i don't
really know how you fix that
and so maybe in that context it's not
super shocking
that you still see that level of uh the
republican party believing
trump didn't really lose joe biden
didn't really win
and what some of you are not going to
believe
is that they are sort of going at it
again
with the voter fraud stuff yeah yes
they're doing it take a listen to this
one of our sponsors today
is covid rescue fund covid rescue fund
is helping small business owners who
have lost
their businesses during covid there are
over one hundred thousand small
businesses
that have had to close their doors since
the pandemic began
there are many organizations out there
helping businesses who are still
open to stay afloat but covet rescue
fund is one of the few organizations
working to help
businesses reopen who have had to close
covet rescue fund crowdsources funds to
provide
grants up to hundred thousand dollars
for these owners to create
new businesses i would implore anyone in
my audience to help covet rescue fund
in their mission by donating at
covidrescufund.org
all money that you give is going to the
mission
not to compensating people who work for
the organization
the founders of covid rescue fund are
big fans of the david pakman show
let's help them bring back as many small
businesses
as we can the link is right underneath
this video